now the classical nimsolarsen opening
that is B3 Bishop B2 and E3
is a very popular opening
amongst all level of chairs and that is
why it is very important for you to have
a good repruta against it
well in my past I have create a Mainline
repruta starting with E5
however in today's lecture I am going to
propose a very special line which not
only contain some cool tricks but
overall Black's opening idea is very
easy to remember and fun to play over
the ball
so after the move B3 my proposal here is
you already play this surprising move C5
and I must tell you that I have gone
through many rapruta of the B3 and many
authors has not taken this move
seriously and some of them already
skipped it
so I think already at this point you
surprised your opponent
and the big point is after the move
Bishop to B2
we want to play the Botwin structure
starting with Knight to C6 where as I
highlighted over here
if white doesn't counter in the center
this is the overall plan from the black
side
in case if you get confused let me show
you a complete piece layout of the black
where the most important part is
look at this bishop it has been
completely locked up
and black has multiple Wing to create
his attack so he can play the move F5
and goes for the king side attack or
else he can play Rook to B8 and start
going on the coincide
more about the structures I have covered
in my Universal chess opening against
all Sicilians so you definitely don't
want to miss out
okay so without the further Ado let's
get started
after Bishop to B2 we are going to play
Knight to C6
and in this video I am only going to
consider the classical Larson opening
that start with E3 whereupon we are
going to respond with E5
so you can easily see now we have put
the block roll to this doctor bishop and
accordingly as per the database these
are the two popular choices from the
white
the first choice I want to consider is
Knight to F3
attacking on E5
and if you know the bot week very well
then you can easily churn out the next
move yup D6 supporting the E Pawn
now I can't believe how many people has
fallen for the move d4 as you can see
from the database there are roughly 10
000 games goes into this direction where
I'm afraid black instantly get a winning
position
here the tricky platform start with
C captures D4 and after e captures D4
the key move E4
sets up some huge problem for the white
well white can already go wrong if you
choose the move D5 here which is again
played in roughly 1200 games
whereupon now black is clearly winning
how you definitely want to pause the
video and find it by yourself
I am showing you right now
the big tactical point is after Pawn
takes night
Pawn take C6
now black has the control of the E2
square that means this chair is very
little
and sadly enough white has to move the
King on the D2 Square
whereupon the fund doesn't end here guys
as we can win the peace yep you got it
right
Pawn takes G2 Bishop takes G2 and now
this lovely check finished the game on
the spot
so this trick is more common in this
line so you do better watch out for it
foreign
Ty of the games continue with Knight F
to D2 attacking only four whereupon
black Reveals His idea now we played the
move D5 and completely locked down this
poor Bishop and in order to free up what
has to react very quickly in the center
and that's why the main line goes as
follow
Seafood trying to undermine black plays
Knight to F6
if C captures D5 then Queen captures D5
really helps the black
so accordingly the best response here is
Knight to C3
white has a simple point that you can't
take on D4 as Knight captures D5 is
extremely strong
but instead of all this black has a very
nice and a strong move in this position
namely Bishop to B4 and after this
however white rigors it is black who is
coming out on tour
for example if we go with the most
famous Choice C captures D5
then after the following sequence
Bishop takes C3 Bishop takes C3 and now
Knight captures D5 create some huge
problem for the white
well the first thing first here white
cannot take on e4 the simple reason is
this Knight is an overload piece and the
way we can exploit It Is by playing
Castle on the king's side where black
has a very simple idea that is Rook to
E8 and then take this Knight
something which white cannot avoid it
so for example a sample line can go like
this bishop to B2 Rook to E8 F3 and F5
wins the piece
so that means white has to be very
careful and he cannot simply take the
pawn here
well the most accurate response is
Bishop to B2 but after this black simply
Castle on the king side
and I can't believe
Bishop to E2 Bishop to C4 are the most
popular choices
but I'm afraid they cannot hold the
ground for the world
for example one of my recent game my
opponent choose the most popular choice
Bishop to C4
trying to Castle on the king side
I played Knight to F4 attacking on G2
but after a White Castle
just pay attention guys and look at the
Tactical ideas black and generate from
this position
next move can you guessed it
well I didn't find it when the first
time I see it
you are a genius if you see the move
[Music]
what a move
and the point is now if I foolishly take
this Pawn then after Queen to G5 he has
a double attack and at least he is
winning the piece
so nope after B5 white can't take that
pawn that means this bishop has to sadly
retrieve back to E2
whereupon black unleash the kraken
congratulations if you see the move
Bishop to S3
well after this white position is
completely collapsing the G2 is hanging
and if he take it then the following
continuation completely gives black an
upper hand
Queen to G5
Bishop to G4
F5
King to H1
tix quintix and queen to defy
just look at Black's position
he has multiple threads Number One E3 or
discover check number two there is a
double attack on D4 number three
very easy attacking scheme The Rook
swinger and all together what is
completely losing from this
so you can see how dangerous these lines
are and even though white followed the
main line for a while the end result
shows that it is black who completely
dictate the game from the opening stage
the second move I want to consider is
Bishop to B5
so idea is very simple white wants to
take the Knight and then lash out with
D4
we are going to respond with a true bot
winning style Knight G to E7
well now D4 is completely out of the
equation
as black has this little check which
finished the game on the spot
has Knight to C3 doesn't hold the ground
because after Pawn takes Pawn takes and
the move C captures D4 the end result
Black coming out as a peace advantage
and just eighth move of the game
so nope white still cannot play the move
d4 after Knight E7
so he wants to continue with Knight to
F3
hoping that if black plays the move D6
then D4 is indeed a strong reply due to
the spin knot
well I completely agree with that but
black has an equally nice reply here
namely F6
and that sets up another tricky platform
as now if y doesn't go for D4 then we
are definitely looking at the move D5
so white has to go for it but after the
following sequence
Knight to C3
Pawn takes D4 it takes D4
and now the star move Knight to D5
gives black a complete opening advantage
there is a small trap here guys that if
your opponent continue with Queen to D2
trying to protect the Knight
well guess what Bishop to B4 and white
indeed losing the piece
so nope Queen to D2 is right out of the
equation the only accurate sequence
start with Bishop takes C6 but even
after this at the end it is black who
dominate the position
here black should start with b capture
C6
and White's tactical idea is he wants to
Castle so that when black get the peace
he can pin down this piece and regain it
back
okay no issues
first we are going to hit this Knight
with E4
and after Bishop capture C3
the queen can slide across on F5 Square
to defend the E4 Pawn
after Queen to E3 and D5 just look at
this position guys
not only black obtain a wonderful Center
but he has also a bishop pair and when
he managed to Castle
even though the material is equal if you
turn on the engine here
it already gives black a huge advantage
which how often you get from any other
lines
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile tricky line
against the Larson opening remember
after the move Bishop to B2 we want to
play bot winning structure starting with
Knight to C6 and as I have shown in this
video after E3 and E5 it doesn't matter
however white plays
both the choices gives black an opening
advantage and a fun position to play
something which you definitely want to
consider in the tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care